what is going on everybody and welcome
to part 2 of our deep learning with
Python tensorflow in Karros tutorial in
this tutorial what we're going to be
talking about is how to load in an
outside data set the outside data set
we're going to use is this cats and dogs
data set from Microsoft it was for
initially a kaggle challenge and the
idea is to take pictures of cats and
dogs and then identify them by feeding
them through a neural network and having
the neural network say whether or not
that's a cat or a dog so go ahead and
download that data set and then once you
have that data set let me pull up an
example here what you should see is like
this so you should get two directories
these two I've added these two things
I've added in but what you should have
is cat and dog and then in here you
should have some like images of cats and
dogs in this case bunch of dogs so each
one has like 12,500 samples so you
should have plenty of examples to teach
a model what's a cat and what's a dog so
go ahead and download those extract
those and then we'll come over here and
we will get to work so we're gonna
import first of all numpy is and P we're
gonna import Metz plot Lib dots pie plot
as p LT we're going to import OS we're
gonna import cv to and from and actually
it's just CB - if you don't have numpy
pip install numpy if you don't have an
apple lib pip install matplotlib but if
you don't have cv to you will need to do
a pip install OpenCV - python alright
once we have those basically I'm gonna
use matplotlib just to show the image
we're going to use OS to iterate through
directories and join paths CB - tis show
or I'm sorry to do some image operations
and then numpy to do various array
operations so the first thing we're
gonna do is specify a data directory my
data is located in my X files under data
sets and pip images then we're going to
have categories that
two categories we've got to deal with
here are dog and cat
I can't leave those different and in
fact we should probably double quote
since we double quoted the other ones so
now what we want to do is iterate
through all of the are examples of dog
and cat so the way we're going to do
that is for category in categories what
do we want to do well we're gonna say
path is OS not path that join dated dirt
and whatever that category is so
basically this just gets our us into our
basically the path to cats or dogs
Durer now we want to say is for image in
OS dot lister that path so it'll just be
a bunch of these images basically
whether it are named by just number once
we have that we can just iterate through
all of those images so the images are we
can convert them immediately to an array
with CV to dot M read and we can read
those with OS that path join and we're
going to join path and image now and
that's the full path to that image then
what we're gonna do is we're gonna
convert it to grayscale so we read in
that image and then we say C V to C V to
M read underscore grayscale so we're
gonna convert it to grayscale because
one you know RGB data is three times the
size of grayscale data and I just don't
think that color is that essential in
this specific task and a lot of
identifying tasks it is but at least in
the you know the difference between a
cat and a dog yes they have a lot of
color but does the is the color the
differentiating factor we're doing cats
and dogs I don't think so if it was like
you know dog versus some reptile or
something like that then yeah probably
you'd want to bring in color okay so
once we've done that the next thing that
we want to do is like we can at least we
can graph this and look at what we're
dealing with just to make sure it's what
we expect so peel t2m show image array c
map equals gray again the only reason
I'm using matplotlib here is
I don't know how to do like inline in
Jupiter notebook with CV - I'm sure
there's a way if somebody knows it go
ahead and leave it below then I'm just
gonna throw a break here in a break just
so we can look at this picture real
quick so as you can see it's a grayscale
image of a dog
no surprise there it's kind of what we
expected
also our data this is what our data
looks like image array okay just a bunch
of numbers now what if we didn't convert
it to grayscale so in this case you can
see it's just a bunch of number you know
pixel values here in this 2d array what
if we didn't do grayscale though and
what if we just did this blue dog now no
longer is it 2d because these are actual
RGB actually probably BG are I believe
is how cv2 reads things and that's why
this is all why the dog is a blue in the
photo anyway we're gonna we are going to
keep grayscale though and just take a
note you know like what how that changes
your your actual data so for example we
could say image ray dot shape for
example there and it's a 398 by 500
which brings us to the next problem we
have which is you can even tell like
some of the all these dogs are like
different shaped photos some are
landscapes some are portraits some are
square and we really need everything to
be normalized at all you know if at all
possible there are ways to have variable
sized images to make classifications on
but in the interest of keeping things as
simple as possible we'd like to make
everything the same shape so that's what
we're going to do next now we have to
decide on a shape so for example what if
we say image size 50 so maybe we're
gonna try every image is a 50 by 50 so
the way we would do that is just new
array equals CB to re size and we resize
the image array and then we do image
size image size and that's our new array
and we really should look at it so em
show new array and then see map for the
color map oh my gosh can we get this
please gray and then PLT not show so I
can still tell that's a dog but
eventually we can't write if I we do 10
make it a 10 by 10
I can't tell that's a dog I don't think
anybody can we go with 20 still probably
not maybe though you might be able to
get away with it at 30 it's still pretty
hard but now you can start to see like
you know like the for armor like it's
the wrist you know the area after the
wrist the hand of a dog I guess I don't
know
anyways that's usually longer in dogs so
I could make this classification at this
point but you know at 50 I'm pretty
comfortable but you do have to be
careful because this dog takes up quite
a bit of the image whereas some of these
might not like for example I'm sure I
can find one eventually this ones are
pretty small he blends into the bench
quite a bit most of these are pretty
pretty well done actually but sometimes
you know it won't it'll be smaller part
of the image and it'll be a little
harder when we make it a small image
look at this camo dog anyway
so keep that in mind I'm gonna I guess
I'll stick with 50 we'll see how that
goes so once you decide on the size that
you want to go with let's go ahead and
create our training data set so I'm
gonna say training data equals an empty
list and then I'm gonna start this
function that I'm gonna call create
training data and I'm gonna give myself
I'm just gonna say pass I'm just gonna
get myself some space here there you go
okay create training data and what we
want to do is now iterate through
everything and build the data set so I'm
just gonna take this copy and then come
down here paste it in tab this over now
the next thing we need to do is we are
norm that we're kind of like in our
Emnes dataset right did we we we have to
map basically we got the features as
numbers but our label or classification
is not yet a number right we can't map
things to a string dog or a string cat
right we need to map things to some sort
of numerical values so we're gonna say 0
is a dog 1 is a cat and the way we can
do that is we could just get the index
value of dog and cat and make that index
value in that list the arbitrary
classification it doesn't matter which
one is the one in which one is 0 it's
just you have to convert to a number so
the
we're gonna do that is I'm just gonna
say class underscore num is going to be
equal to categories dot index index
lowercase whatever that category is so
zero for a dog 1 for a cat now we're
going to iterate over the images I we
don't need to show them we don't need to
break any more and all I want to do now
is resize with this new array so we'll
come down here we'll perform that
resizing operation and I think that's
about it so now we just want to append
this to our training data list above
there so training underscore data dot of
hand and we want to append our new
underscore array and whatever that
classification is so class underscore
num okay so we want to do that for
everything the other thing we probably
should do is for image we price it in
case this and a try and except I've been
through this data set before and some of
the images are like broken so accept
exception e and you know what I'm gonna
do I am gonna I'm just gonna pass
actually I already know that there's
some that are broken you normally you
would throw the exception so you could
read it and figure out what's going
wrong but I'm gonna go ahead and just
pass but there's like three will get
like an OS error and some other warning
information and all that fun stuff but
I'll just pass for now create training
data and then running that and then
whenever that's done let's go ahead and
print print the Len of training data now
a couple things we should talk about is
the balance of your training data so
it's really important that your training
data especially like in the case of
classification is properly balanced so
in the case of a binary choice like we
have cats and dogs you want to make sure
you have fifty fifty right just as many
cats in just as many dogs now sometimes
you can have different numbers and then
when you train the model you can inform
the model and say hey these are our
class weights so they have a weights
that you can pass in the way this will
work
is it will
eight the you know the loss a little
little differently in an attempt to
handle for your imbalance data set but
if at all possible you definitely want
to balance the data set instead so but
sometimes like let's say you had so
let's say you had a day so there was 75%
dog 25% cat you feed that through the
neural network in the neural networks
gonna learn really quickly just always
predict dog and you'll be 75 percent
right and then when it tries to learn
from there it's gonna have a really
really hard time so so if you balance it
so it's a perfect 50/50 you'll be better
the next thing you want to do is shuffle
the data so we've got the training data
but as you can see the first thing we
did was iterate over the category then
go from there so everything's dot all
dogs and then all cats well if you feed
that to the neural network it's gonna
learn okay only predict dog and then it
switches over to cats and it's like I'm
wrong I'm wrong I'm wrong okay cat cat
everything's a cat and then it just
keeps going back and forth it's probably
not gonna learn very well that way
either so we definitely want to shuffle
the data so we can import random and
then we can do a random not full there
we go
training data sense training is a list
mutable there it is it's already
shuffled at this point so for example we
could now for I don't know sample in
training data we we can check that our
labels are correct by doing print sample
one so this will be the label so sample
zero with would be a whole we went
through them all anyways sample zero
would be unless there's two of to ten
here would be the actual image array
itself I don't want to run the whole
thing all over again
well we'll just wait for that that's
fine so now let's do the let's take this
data now and now that it's shuffled
let's pack it into the variables that
we're going to use right before we feed
it into our neural network so that's
going to be an empty list for X and an
empty list for wine general capital X is
your feature set lowercase Y is your
labels sometimes you'll see a tray next
sy and like all these kinds of things
and we could we can split those up but
we can still we can actually specify a
validation set so you don't have to
split them up sometimes you may do that
anyways but
you don't really have to do that so you
can use built-in methods to to properly
do an out-of-sample test okay so now
we're going to say four features label
in training data we're going to X dot
append features y dot a pen dot append
label so we build those out into lists
and we really can't pass especially for
the features we can't pass a list to the
neural network I wish we could I think
we should be able to especially if we're
using a high level API like Kaos it's
kind of silly that we still got to do
this hopefully soon one day this will
change but we need to convert both
things
well actually Y can stay lists but X has
to be first of all an umpire array so
let's go ahead and do that so x equals
NP array X but also we need to reshape
it to be negative 1 by the shape of each
X so negative 1 is just how many
features do we have well you can say
negative 1 and that's kind of a
catch-all it's anything any number and
then we can say we know the shape of the
data to be image size by image size you
could also do like X 1 0 X 1 1 and so on
but anyways we'll just go with this so
image size by image size and then by 1
so this one is because it is a grayscale
and just as a bit of a homework
challenge for you guys I encourage you
to attempt to make a confident to work
rather than with grayscale work with
color images so see if you can convert
what we're going to build here from a
greyscale convolutional neural network
to B color so just as an aside that
might be the hardest thing to remember
to do is change that one to a three
because then it would be three values so
that's what we have to do again I think
this reshape is kind of silly
I wish somebody from hopefully Karros
eventually would make this not be a
requirement we should not have to deal
with that shape it should just
intelligently shavings there's always
the same kind of thing like you always
have to do this same step and it's silly
ok so once we have our data
uh-oh
EXO when did we convert it first of all
when do we define an x max not a pen
when did it get converted when did we
use an X I'm just tripping out I guess
cuz I never ran this I don't know when
we had an X so why how when was X a
thing oh man someone's got to help me
out with that one
when did X become an umpire a before
this was run did we ever use an X
variable or maybe it's cuz I'm redoing
this and X already did have a yeah so
the first recording got screwed up
that's what happened man that was
killing me I was like wait a second so X
I already was if I should have restarted
the kernel anyway moving along okay the
last thing we want to do is we want to
save these so you don't want to generate
your data like you don't want to like do
all this crunching and reshaping all
that every single time because chances
are you're gonna be like tweaking your
model so the reality of neural networks
is that you don't have the answer right
away or you're not working on a problem
that's as easy as the one that we're
about to be working on so it's gonna be
it's not gonna be as simple as like oh
just throw them all together use exactly
these you know features and this many
nodes this many layers you're not gonna
know you're gonna be tweaking so you
don't want to have to be rebuilding your
data set every time so the last thing
we're gonna do is we're gonna once we've
created our training data we're just
gonna import Pikul and then in some way
you don't have to use pickle we could mm
PI not save or whatever somehow save
your data so you don't to redo it every
time so pickle out equals open and I'm
gonna open X dot pickle X down pick W be
pickled dump we want to dump X we're to
pickle out and then pickle pickle out
dot close and then we want to do the
same thing for the Y so I'm just gonna
do why come down
why and then later if we want to read it
back in you can do something like this
like pickle underscore in equals open X
dot pickle RB and then or really know
what kind of did an extra step there but
anyway x equals pickled lode pickle in
okay and then x1 for example is our
image and then x so it'll be our feature
basically so that would be our image and
then Y one would be the label for x1
anyways that's all for now what we're
gonna do is in the next tutorial we're
gonna take this data set that we've you
know compiled and then we're gonna feed
it through our convolutional neural
network after going over some of the
basics of confidence and all that so if
you've got questions comments concerns
whatever something you think could be
done better
whatever feel free to leave them below
otherwise I will see you guys in the
next tutorial where we are gonna feed it
through a neural network and hopefully
get our correct classifications so till
next time